adam levine speaking out after an
instagram model accuses him of cheating
on his wife biati prinsloo essentially
i was having an affair with a man who's
married to a victory secret model
that's sumner stroh whose tick-tock is
blowing up after she claims she had an
affair with the musician at the time you
know i was
young i was naive and
i mean quite frankly i feel exploited i
wasn't in the scene like i am now um so
i was definitely very easily manipulated
maroon 5 is practically
elevator music at this point so i'm sure
you know who adam levine is
um
but adam and i were seeing each other
for about a year
she then shared these screenshots of her
and adam's alleged dms they read in part
quote it is truly unreal how [ __ ] hot
you are like it blows my mind you are 50
times hotter in person and so am i
sumner released those screenshots after
adam allegedly reached out to her again
months after their first interactions
this time bringing up his and biati's
baby on the way he said okay serious
question i'm having another baby and if
it's a boy i really uh want to name it
sumner you okay with that dead serious
um
i was like
i'm in hell like i have to be in hell at
this point
i mean my morals were unknowingly
compromised i was completely manipulated
24 hours later and the maroon 5 frontman
is firing back at sumner's claims in a
statement of his own posting quote a lot
is being said about me right now and i
want to clear the air i used poor
judgment in speaking with anyone other
than my wife in any kind of flirtatious
manner i did not have an affair
nevertheless i crossed the line during a
regrettable period in my life adam adds
that in certain instances it became
inappropriate the real you no matter
like it or not the real you is coming
out
no matter how close you play your cards
you better just embrace it
adam also hints at how he and biati are
navigating this scandal saying he's
taken proactive steps to remedy the
situation
my wife and my family is all i care
about in this world to be this naive and
stupid enough to risk the only thing
that truly matters to me was my greatest
mistake i could ever make i will never
make it again i take full responsibility
we will get through it and we will get
through it together i think we've
we've set a pretty high standard for us
as a couple individual the two of us
aside from the kids and family and all
of that to really just
make sure we're good and one if we're
good the kids are good families are good
so we're just a good team
just last week biati confirmed she was
pregnant with baby number three posting
baby bump pics to instagram the couple
is already parents to daughters dusty
rose and geo grace biati has not yet
commented on the allegations
[Music]
you